un hangar entièrement dévastés par les
flammes il hier soir sur la commune
dauphin et le désarroi ce matin pour cet
agriculteur qui a perdu l'intégralité de
ces animaux dans l' incendie
au total près de sept mille volailles
poules pintades et poussins un sinistre
dont l'origine pourrait s'expliquer par
les forts coups de vent de la nuit
dernière on voit bien qu'il ya une
fenêtre qui est tombé puis basse est
tombé pile haut niveau c'est qu'il y
avait des systèmes de chauffage pour les
poussins donc c'est ça qu'a dû engendrer
l'incendié à l'intérieur un feu qui a
rapidement consumées l'ensemble de la
structure
s'il ya une étincelle épique
il ya quelque chose qui peut brûler en
dessous là c'est généralement comme on
met du copo pour pas que ça brûle puis
ça a dû faire d'une étincelle un endroit
sûr les bottes de paille qui était
stocké plus loin puis ben ça en deux
n'est pas un désastre pour cet éleveur
qui compte relancer ou plutôt son
exploitation
on va reconstruire différemment et puis
comme on dit il faut aller de l'avant
maintenant on n'a pas trop le choix